microwave I'm bummed casual doesn't
garlic right come around actually
Michael neither like a visible adapt see
with clarity subtle my name is Gary
Thomas I've been telling you Accountants
of equity I'll triple they've given a
pedigree to be enough pleasure my
faculties putting the work that I'm
doing are the moving furniture I think
we have a real hardcore real hug via
YouTube strategy meaning
like a Monday morning have to go to a
seven-hour off-site from my leadership
team work through some organizational
changes strategies concept to be a lot
of fun a lot of work you guys have been
following the narrative all day with the
CFO all hands on company meeting this
full day of off-site so doing our thing
[Music]
getting alignment getting alignment with
your direct reports whether that's one
person or 30 is essential if your team
is not cohesive you've got no shot pay
attention to March Madness right now the
subtleties are the teams that are
winning it's the cohesiveness of those
five that matter so much it's like a
ballet and I tell businesses if you have
anything and this is a great chance to
get value out of my vlog if right now
the three or four most important people
that work for you are not aligned with
you on vision on how much they make on
where you're going if you're not
completely completely cohesive
completely step by step like a perfect
symphony you're vulnerable and it's up
to you
the leader to make that work and so you
need to face the things that may be ugly
your shortcomings their shortcomings
limits your brother but communication
amongst the top leadership the person
and the direct people that execute that
vision has to be seamless actor has to
that's what this day is about
hello
yeah I didn't realize it either
these are like a couple days ago like
what looks to my schedule like where am
I going
are you guys you have any clasps on your
PL like overhead versus revenue no no no
because that's also you know that's just
a that's a that's a theoretical exercise
I want to know I want to know what you
want to do here about calling an email I
care them buying something until DJ buy
something we're not done until they
really buy something we're not done with
our mission just who that we mailed them
one time we got to email them again we
got to send them a flyer in the mail we
got to call them again get them on the
phone
[Music]
it's not a small number it's a start you
know you know what the best part is we
literally don't stop until they like so
on Saturday because it's a weekend and
people have different numbers and they
work differently we call everybody every
single person Saturday Brandon I
[Music]
actually think those ten six-packs
should sell especially because you have
a hitter's list that you'll be able to
get it done you know I don't think
hoping is a good strategy when I talk
what else to [ __ ] matters
[Music]